on regarde dans les chambres si
effectivement il y en a pas un qui
détendent
mais une belle surprise
de me le dire
[Musique]
il voulait sortir des plateaux prendre
l'air tâter le terrain
ils ne vont pas être déçus
Carole Rousseau et Benjamin Castaldi
partent à la rencontre d'hommes et de
femmes ordinaires au métier
extraordinaire
[Musique]
mes yeux à 20 km à l'ouest de Lyon
immersion immédiate dans une école pas
comme les autres ici on offre une
deuxième chance à des jeunes de 18 à 25
ans qui ont décroché en France il serait
près d'un million sans emploi sans
formation et sans repère
très spécial huit mois c'est le temps
qu'ils auront pour réapprendre les
rudiment du vivre ensemble et trouver un
emploi
au programme
maths français entretien d'embauche
permis de conduire le tout dans un cadre
quasi militaire
créé en 2005 suite aux émeutes en
banlieue l'établissement public
d'insertion de la défense fête cette
année ses 10 ans plus de 28 000 jeunes
sont déjà passés par ces centres
d'insertion professionnelle et sociale
dis pas le mot élève non on dit pas le
mot école non plus j'imagine non
je vais suivre Ericsson et Marina ils
sont ici depuis six mois et se battent
pour surmonter leurs difficultés
ces jeunes luttent pour se faire une
place dans le monde des adultes
je vais partager leurs épreuves c'est
pas grave
leur moment de joie
[Rires]
pendant une semaine
à disposition dans les 18 centres de
lipides la journée commence de la même
manière au même moment par le
rassemblement sous les drapeaux à 7h45
Laurent connaît parfaitement ce rituel
qui arithmé toute sa vie de légionnaires
devenu moniteur il entend bien faire
comprendre la portée de ce moment
symbolique à ces jeunes recrues
à respecter c'est extrêmement important
on va dire c'est le moment de la journée
ou honnêtement on plaisante pas là
c'est du sérieux
le directeur prend lui aussi cette
cérémonie très au sérieux ancienne
officier de l'armée de terre il a mis
des générations de soldats au
garde-à-vous
bonjour à tous repos aujourd'hui ce sont
des grands ados cabossés par la vie
qu'il doit remettre en état de marche
marina kleindeins et Ericsson Gomez
partagent la même section le compte à
rebours a déjà commencé il ne leur reste
que deux mois pour se préparer au monde
extérieur après ils seront de nouveau
livrés à eux-mêmes
[Musique]
contre nous de la
sanglant marseillaise uniforme
garde-à-vous pas de doute c'est bien le
ministère de la Défense qui a eu l'idée
de ses centres d'insertion mais ici on
ne réinvente pas le service militaire
les jeunes ont les prépare à se battre
pour se faire une place dans la vie
active ici on leur enseigne la confiance
en soi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les élèves ont plutôt les volontaires
comme on les appelle ici se dirigent en
Cancer vers leur salle de cours
[Musique]
les R2 sur une colonne s'il vous plaît
oui Marie n'est pas un ancien militaire
dans sa vie d'avance il a dirigé
plusieurs établissements de formation
professionnelle il a été l'un des
premiers à croire dans cette école d'un
nouveau genre une colonne
pour le plaisir d'accompagner ces jeunes
déboussolés il est redevenu simple
professeur
[Musique]
avant de vous asseoir on va peut-être
modifier un petit peu la salle on va
faire une étoile si on est d'accord
pendant un instant j'ai l'impression de
retourner au collège mais les méthodes
de Louis-Marie vont vite me faire
oublier cette sensation
vous pouvez vous asseoir merci ici on ne
se remet pas seulement à niveau en
français et en maths on apprend aussi à
mieux se connaître à exprimer ses
sentiments avec des mots
quels sont les cinq gardiens qui sont en
vous c'est 5 je dirais 5 traits de
personnalités vous avez déjà une seconde
vous ça suffisait et encore
l'hameçon
qui est en vous c'est lequel aujourd'hui
à l'heure où nous parlons a le plus
d'importance vous me les classes
de professeur à élève
je fais des devoirs
une activité
vous n'êtes pas de devoirs
si vous voulez dormir vous pouvez dormir
et comme je sais que ça vous intéresse
oui mais ça me fait réfléchir s'il vous
plaît
demain matin vous allez à un entretien
d'embauche
quel est le l'ange gardien que vous
allez mettre en avant de presque
efficace pourquoi
la motivation
l'envie
Loïc ça vient
il y a du forfait
bien on peut faire une petite mise en
commun le guerrier oui
l'enfant
il se voit tous en guerrier comme si la
vie n'était qu'une suite de coups à
prendre et à donner bouffon j'ai mis
humour
est-ce que vous avez est-ce que vous
êtes entouré d'humour ou c'est vous qui
est à l'origine de l'humour
ne pas me prendre au sérieux j'aimerais
faire rire aussi le témoin numéro 8
c'est moi amoureux
de la vie d'être à l'équipe avec vous de
faire ce que mon métier ça j'aime désolé
par contre le bouffon je mettrais bien
en deuxième parce que comme vous savez
nous travaillons sérieusement mais je ne
suis pas sérieux parce que je trouve que
la vie est trop dure pour ne pas la
gérer la croquer tous les jours de
profiter de tous les bons moments que je
peux avoir même dans la difficulté quand
vous allez vers l'emploi effectivement
c'est celui-ci à qui on fait appel je
l'aurai ce poste je me battrai je suis
le meilleur et quand il pose la question
toute la subtilité du cours de Louis
Marie amener doucement ces jeunes à
prendre conscience du combat qui
s'annonce pour trouver un travail mais
sans jamais leur faire la leçon quand
vous passez de l'adolescence à l'adulte
en devenir ben effectivement il faut
s'éloigner de l'enfant mais on peut
toujours garder un cœur d'enfants
et qu'est-ce que ça vous fait que je
sois un enfant ça nous donne de la joie
oui et puis
déjà pas mal
éprouver de la joie en classe une
victoire pour Louis-Marie car pour ces
jeunes l'école n'a souvent été qu'un
cauchemar et quel est le mot de trois
lettres que je vous interdit
commence par un N
en venant monsieur je suis
tous ces mots là qui vous ont mis en
situation difficile dans les
établissements vous étiez avant vous
étiez pas plus en difficulté que les
autres mais le système ne vous convenait
pas et après on vous a catalogué comme
étant un élève nul et après excusez-moi
du peu vous l'avez entretenu
mademoiselle messieurs vous pouvez
enlever la méthode de Louis-Marie c'est
un concentré d'épide pour remotiver ces
jeunes il faut faire table rase du passé
je trouve que vous nous oubliez souvent
non mais faites attention vous savez
très bien que théoriquement je devrais
le confisquer
[Rires]
vous vous en sortez bien et vous dévoile
le gant là
mais j'accepte vos excuses alors
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait là on a fait un
médiation culturelle c'est un atelier
l'atelier c'est pas un cours non je ne
fais jamais voilà pour tout à l'heure
non on dit pas le mot école non plus
j'imagine non on fait jamais référence à
ce qui a pu être pour nous essayons
d'éviter tous les mots qui ont une
connotation négative à l'orega nous
sommes là pour les faire réussir donc
pour moi élève classe cours français
même le français n'est pas des fois je
mets expression culture générale ou
dépoussiérage de cerveau j'utilise plein
de petits mots différents que toutes ces
mots qui les rappellent ce qu'ils
avaient souffrir en fait j'ai vu une
jeune fille moi qui quand elle venait
aux ateliers mathématiques elles étaient
en pleurs puis un bon matin nous allons
savoir pourquoi prouve et elle a décidé
de réussir ça marche donc il faut
arriver à provoquer le déclic et c'est
là qu'il faut utiliser de tous les
stratèges possibles pour qu'il puisse
prendre goût et s'approprie la matière
ici tout ne se joue pas devant un
tableau il y a aussi les ateliers
d'expression karaoké maquettisme photos
des cours pratiques où l'on apprend sans
s'en rendre compte la méthode la rigueur
et la discipline comme ici en cuisine
donc monsieur Gomez et vous allez Rocha
vous allez être avec Carole Rousseau et
au fourneau c'est Chloé une ancienne
gendarme qui donne le ton
il y a un miroir
ça marche
vous êtes magnifique
même si tout se déroule dans la bonne
humeur on n'est pas vraiment là pour
rigoler
[Musique]
cuisiner respecter les règles d'hygiène
maîtriser les calculs simples et les
unités de mesure
soyez précis on peut en mettre bien des
choses dans une simple recette de
pâtisserie lyonnaise pas mal d'avoir une
assistante non vous en pensez quoi
ça fait bien
tu veux regarder elle est pas terrible
vous inquiétez pas je dirais que c'est
de ma faute
[Musique]
allez hop non vous terminez votre pâte
et après vous goûtez oh on arrête de
s'éparpiller là on peut terminer les
choses convenablement
ce soir le dessert sera fait maison en
deux heures nous avons sorti 400 bugnes
on a réussi encore une fois à sortir les
desserts en temps et en heure donc bah
allez-y vous pouvez désormais déguster
pour moi
[Rires]
décrochage à l'école et leur prise en
main dans ses centres il s'est passé
plusieurs années ils ont enchaîné galère
échecs et frustrations quand ils
arrivent ici ils sont incapables de se
projeter dans l'avenir ils n'ont
confiance ni en eux ni en la République
[Musique]
dans le département il y a plusieurs
communes
et l'ensemble de certaines communes
forme des cantons
Daniel a passé 26 ans sous les drapeaux
il aimerait bien transmettre à ces
jeunes recrues son engagement au service
du pays sa fibre citoyenne
combien il y en a-t-il qui possèdent
leur carte d'électeurs
jamais
si je vais voter ça va pas changer grand
chose ça sera toujours pareil donc ça
sert à rien
[Musique]
nous promet des trucs des choses ils le
font pas comme les changements c'est
maintenant qu'on a jamais on n'a jamais
vu du changement
à quoi sert
où nous sommes
je vous pose la question
mais ça mais ça c'est venu les pites
comme ça parce que les gens n'allaient
pas voter ils restaient dans leur coin
et puis il y a quelqu'un en cachette qui
a dit ben on va créer les pides parce
que il y a des jeunes en difficulté
et vous vous posez pas la question de
savoir comment est né cet établissement
qui paye pourquoi vous êtes ici alors
moi je peux entendre que en effet
parfois il y en a qui mettent les jeunes
de côté mais c'est pas le cas pour tout
faut pas généraliser on m'a jamais
appelé par exemple moi j'appelle
j'appelle et après une fois que
j'appelle la personne elle me répond non
vous prend pas parce que il y avait un
tel comme ça on a pris quelqu'un d'autre
alors qu'on vous a on m'a on m'a promis
de prendre la place si il se place là
moi je veux me sentir comment
demain vous allez partir de lipides tout
le monde va pas vous ouvrir ses bras
pour dire venez travailler chez moi je
le sais par contre par contre vous devez
avoir des attitudes pour aller chercher
le travail
c'est pas parce qu'on vous a dit une
seule fois ben non que vous devez
baisser les bras et c'est vrai que vous
allez essuyer des échecs il faut se
remettre parfois aussi en question se
dire pourquoi ça a pas marché pourquoi
la personne aussi également un moment
donné elle a décidé de pas vous appeler
c'est pas ça parce que il dit ouais et
après il vous dit non qui a plus
d'expérience que vous c'est vrai et ça
arrivera encore monsieur moi dit ça
arrivera hélas il ne teste pas il
pourrait nous dire bah on vous prend on
essaye et si ça va on continue tout le
monde n'a pas de l'expérience et il veut
justement avoir un début de d'expérience
mademoiselle il faut aller les chercher
elles vont pas venir toute seule comme
ça et que ça va tomber du ciel il faut
se battre et vous avez raison monsieur
ça n'est quand vous dit qu'il faut
savoir rebondir personne vous dites ça
fait ça ce que je veux vous dire c'est
c'est vous qui décidez monsieur moi dit
ça va aller il va se précipiter à la
mairie pour s'inscrire sur les listes
électorales on a bien compris
je vous invite d'aller manger
gratuitement
bon appétit et merci à vous en tout cas
à travers des supports comme les
élections et ben ils vont dévier
inconsciemment ou consciemment sur leur
crainte de la pré-épide en tant qu'homme
je comprends et je peux comprendre leur
colère mais je suis aussi un éducateur
et ce rôle d'éducateur je me dois aussi
de leur dire attention la vie de demain
ça sera ça ça et ça voilà tout
simplement c'est une réalité que le
monde dans lequel ils vont évoluer ils
évoluent déjà est extrêmement difficile
pour les jeunes oui oui elle est
difficile parce que
ils ont absolument rien et d'ailleurs
c'est la caractéristique de l'épître
c'est à dire qu'on prend des jeunes
justement les PID c'est la force de cet
établissement c'est que l'on prend des
des jeunes qui ont on va dire tiens tout
simplement
et il faut qu'on les mette dans le
circuit du monde du travail vous voyez
on parle de très très loin
[Musique]
17h30 l'école est finie pour aujourd'hui
comme dans n'importe quel cours de
récréation les jeunes s'amusent et des
compresses
[Applaudissements]
c'est tous les soirs comme ça
tous les volontaires doivent élaborer un
projet professionnel
Marina souhaite devenir aide à la
personne afin de tester ses aptitudes
elle va être convoquée par Pôle Emploi
on n'aime pas le terme test mais en fait
c'est quand même l'objectif est quand
même un petit peu là c'est de voir
comment vous vous comportez par rapport
à ces métiers dans le cadre d'une mise
en situation donc qui va on va y
reprendre un certain nombre de gestes
professionnels marina a une semaine pour
se préparer c'est une étape décisive
dans son parcours d'insertion j'ai déjà
fait des stages mais comme ça à
l'improviste un peu testé sur ce qu'on
fait et du coup c'est
ce stressant on sait pas qu'est-ce qui
va se passer c'est pas parce que à la
limite vous ne validez pas cet exercice
cette fois-ci que vous le validerez
jamais et ça nous permet aussi nous à
l'Épide de mesurer là où vous en êtes et
d'avancer
malgré son CAP de vente elle n'a jamais
réussi à trouver un emploi
préoccupé son père un militaire lui a
parlé de ses écoles de la deuxième
chance elle a déjà passé six mois ici
dans huit semaines son contrat prendra
fin ses camarades ont déjà trouvé un
emploi elles ont quitté le centre
vous êtes toutes seules
c'était quoi les blabla du soir
tout ce qui se passe on parle de tout et
de rien des fois potages de pis puis on
se parle c'est sympa ça fait mieux que
d'être tout seul vous aimez pas être
toute seule pas trop il faut savoir
vivre tout seul aussi
à tout et plus on rigole en fait donc en
quoi vous avez changé depuis que vous
êtes là bon
j'ai pris un peu confiance en moi
j'étais un peu timide réservé
ouais c'est vrai que
parler comme ça
c'est pas des choses que j'ai l'habitude
de faire j'aimais bien écouter les
conneries des autres et puis maintenant
j'aime bien dire ça change tout
pour réussir à dire des bêtises et ça je
suis pas sûr qu'il faut être content
il m'arrive bon est-ce que ça a pas été
trop dur de de s'éloigner de ses parents
vous êtes jeune encore
moi j'ai trouvé que
[Musique]
ça coupait un peu le cordon en fait
on sent plus grand on sent moins le
petit bébé a son papa on sent vraiment
grandir là je crois qu'il y a foot il y
a la cantine
le régime d'Internal ne coupe pas
seulement le cordon avec la famille il
permet aussi de tenir à distance les
mauvaises fréquentations du quartier
tous les volontaires sans exception
vivent donc à l'internat du lundi au
vendredi le week-end il rentre chez
leurs parents pour les moins chanceux
l'établissement dispose d'un appartement
en ville
il est 21h30 extinction des feux dans
deux heures
c'est facile le coucher où ils sont un
peu
excité mais en règle générale ça va
surtout l'hiver parce qu'il fait froid
par contre l'été effectivement il fait
chaud il fait encore jour à cette
heure-là donc c'est un petit peu un
petit peu plus compliqué mais bon
généralement
assez facilement
et quand on quand ses enfants
ils sont grands mais je les vois petit
non mais c'est vrai ils sont grands mais
je les vois on sent que
on sent que ça pousse mais que c'est pas
encore
lit totalement des hommes
à peine tout juste donc ce ne sont pas
des enfants ce sont de jeunes adultes
voilà ils arrivent à faire confiance ils
arrivent à se donner facilement ils sont
pas hyper prudents justement parce
qu'ils ont déjà beaucoup morflé non bah
non parce que je pense qu'ils partent
aussi du principe que ici il se
soutiennent justement beaucoup parce
qu'ils ont pas tous le même passé mais
au moins un vécu un peu similaire avec
des carences un peu similaires aussi et
donc du coup ils se comprennent bien par
rapport à ça je pense
ils sont pas rentrés encore là non mais
là ils vont rentrer et puis il y a les
collègues de la nuit là qui viennent
d'arriver je retrouve Laurent l'ancien
légionnaire il va assurer la permanence
jusqu'à cette heure en principe les
nuits sont calmes
donc là vous allez faire un tour des
chambres pas dans l'immé
où ils sont ils ont encore un peu de
temps pour dialoguer entre eux le seul
chose où à laquelle on doit prêter
attention c'est des plus de circulation
à partir de 22h là sur les terrasses ça
pour ça il y a des soirs c'est un peu
compliqué parce qu'ils essayent
de ce que j'ai pu constater depuis
combien oui monsieur
c'est des jeunes voilà c'est avec tout
ce que ça peut engendrer ça peut être
calme un soir ça peut être un peu plus
énervé le lendemain mais ouais dans
l'ensemble ils sont relativement calme
ils sont relativement calme
contrairement à ce qu'on aurait pu
penser le fait qu'il vienne de quartier
pas forcément super etc ils sont plutôt
ils sont plutôt cool ils sont plutôt
de 300 balles son iPhone 6 et veste là
je vais aller voir ce qui se passe là
parce que ouais
les histoires comme ça à 22h30 enfin
avant à 22h je crois pas trop mais il
faut un bon pourquoi pas
[ __ ] d'accord posez-vous posez-vous
détendez-vous de la galette là c'est bon
on discute par contre vous le savez vous
le savez on est en internat
même si vous absentez de la Chambre ne
serait-ce que deux minutes pour aller à
la laverie récupérer votre linge ou quoi
ne laissez pas si vous laissez la
chambre
pourquoi les gens ils volent pourquoi il
y a des gens qui ont des choses il y a
des choses parce que
les gens à la fois
qui n'aura pas ce que vous vous avez et
qui essaiera de vous le taxer Laurent
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
et ben apparemment jeune femme se fait
piquer elle serait fait pitié un
téléphone
qui vient d'acheter qui est encore
emballée
que les jeunes essayent de s'escomper on
en a pas ou c'est vraiment très rare que
les vols les vols c'est rassurant on
regarde dans les chambres si
effectivement il y en a pas un qui
dépendent voilà ouais ouais pas de trace
de portable mais une belle surprise
dans son sac non mais on a des magiciens
c'est pas un coup boulon parce que ça
c'est un truc pour couple c'est un
taille-haie mais bon il a pas avoir ça
dans sa chambre le jeune c'est pas
franchement une bonne idée
branches je sais pas faire des trucs je
sais même pas pourquoi il a ça dans sa
chambre
systématiquement quand il rentre on fout
leur sac parce que ils peuvent revenir à
la maison se faire confier quelque chose
par un copain qui veut faire passer un
autre etc etc notamment pour tout ce qui
est stupéfiant ou alcool étant donné que
c'est deux de produits qui sont
formellement interdits ici donc on fait
très attention là-dessus maintenant
voilà on n'est pas à l'abri tu ramènes
un truc
j'ai jamais vu ça j'ai jamais vu ça mec
il arrive à passer avec un truc quand
même un bordel qui fait quand même près
d'un mètre quoi mais ça ça mérite une
sanction importante non
alors ça ça va être notifié on en fera
un compte-rendu par mail tout de suite
au référence section qui va qui va gérer
la source voilà
pendant ce temps-là la fouille des
chambres continue
[Musique]
c'est au courant quand même
allez merci monsieur vous c'est une
bonne nuit excusez-moi pour le
dérangement tout ce qui est précieux
vous nous donnez en arrivant au centre
on le met dans le coffre-fort vous le
récupérez à votre sortie comme ça au
moins vous êtes sûrs
finalement les moniteurs ne retrouveront
ni le portable ni l'argent il rédigeront
deux rapports un pour la cisaille
l'autre pour le téléphone
il n'y aura pas d'autres incidence cette
nuit là
[Musique]
madame terrange peut rentrer c'est bon à
côté les gars poubelle et les vider tout
trois fois je leur ai dit de vider la
poubelle la poubelle elle est là mettez
de l'entrain un peu là il est où son
chéri
annoncer une telle nouvelle à un élève
est-ce que ça a pas ça risque pas de le
braquer l'objectif en fait du conseil de
discipline c'est de le faire réagir je
comprends que c'est vachement compliqué
là pour vous vous étiez limite à deux
doigts de partir là
c'est normal c'est normal franchement on
est pas mieux
rester ici indéfiniment
l'internat s'éveille
madame perranche peut rentrer petit
déjeuner dans une demi-heure personne ne
doit être en retard
bonjour
la chambre parce que c'est pas top ça
vous me rangez ça aussi s'il vous plaît
cette salle qui traîne
comment ça monsieur Sané c'est bon à
côté les gars poubelle et les vider tout
c'est surtout l'hygiène donc voir qu'ils
ont fait leur lit vider la poubelle pour
éviter que ça traîne pendant des jours
et des jours et puis voilà l'état des
toilettes voilà et tout ça il faut que
ce soit fait avant 7h parce qu'après il
y a le petit déjeuner il faut limiter
les retards au petit-déjeuner sinon
après ils sont en tube
travaux d'utilité générale donc c'est le
mercredi après-midi il s'occupe de la
propreté du centre
très bien
elles sont déjà parties au petit
déjeuner je vais quand même vérifier la
chambre
ah non
c'est qui
vous faites encore
c'est la première panne de réveil de
Leslie pourtant elle n'échappera pas la
sanction pas de petit déjeuner allez on
fait le lit on se lève on s'active
monsieur de Maria Monsieur Saïd ou
monsieur Hassani trois fois je leur ai
dit de vider la poubelle la poubelle
elle est là vous avez de la chance que
je la [ __ ] pas par terre
ments plus encore qu'à l'école la
pédagogie est affaire de répétitions
trois fois je vous ai demandé quoi
passer un coup dans la salle de bain
vider la poubelle
oui ou non
[Musique]
revoilà Leslie malgré sa panne
d'oreiller ce matin et son retard elle
négocie son petit déjeuner avec Chloé
c'est dur je sais que c'est dur mais bon
c'est tout l'enjeu ici
faire comprendre doucement mais
fermement à ces jeunes que dans le monde
des adultes leurs actes auront des
conséquences ça nous entraîne sur le
travail plus tard qu'on fait la grasse
mat on perdra notre travail en fait donc
bah c'est bien ça nous permet de prendre
un bon rythme de vie en fait
Leslie a quand même eu droit à un petit
café mais elle n'échappera pas aux
travaux d'utilité générale vider cette
poubelle là vider le cendrier qui est là
dans la poubelle j'étais la poubelle et
puis bah ramasser les mégots qui
traînent aux elvaris OK
[Musique]
chez les garçons on ramasse on essuie on
balaie mais là encore la propreté n'est
pas l'enjeu c'est plutôt pour apprendre
à avoir une vie de grand quoi avoir un
travail être propre savoir se lever à
l'heure les bases monsieur Gomez
Erikson de son prénom à 22 ans il a
rejoint sa mère en France à l'âge de 16
ans son père et ses frères sont restés
en Guinée-Bissau parlant mal notre
langue jamais scolarisée sans aucune
qualification il a traîné cinq ans dans
la rue ses débuts dans le centre ont été
difficiles au début c'était un peu un
peu la galère j'ai eu pas mal de fiches
événements
des insultes ça c'est ça sortait souvent
au quartier c'était ça
c'était un peu comme la jungle quoi
tout ça c'est du passé maintenant chez
je sais ce que je veux
Ericson cherche un emploi dans la grande
distribution et pourquoi pas un jour
avoir son propre magasin
ce matin Laurent est en forme les
corvées sont rondement menés
[Musique]
c'est des repères et c'est constamment
tous les jours leur répéter les mêmes
consignes de manière à ce qui les
intègre et qui puisse agir d'eux-mêmes
on essaie de les amener vers à être
autonome c'est tout simplement voilà
c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont perdu à
un moment il faut
nous le but la mission c'est leur donner
le goût quoi il faut qu'il faut qu'ils
aient envie quoi
enlevez-moi les prothèses
après 10 ans de légion Laurent n'a aucun
mal à donner de la voix mettez de
l'entrain un peu là
encadrer des jeunes au quotidien c'est
assez sympa ça permet de rester jeune ça
donne bien la patate et surtout ça donne
ça donne envie on a envie nous quelque
part on a fait des choix de vie qui nous
ont plutôt bien réussi donc on a envie
aussi que ces jeunes ils aient aussi
envie et qui prennent du plaisir à faire
ce qu'ils font tous les jours et qu'ils
avancent
ici il a retrouvé une famille près d'un
encadrant sur deux est un ancien
militaire
pour l'ensemble en commandement
200 jeunes intègrent ce centre chaque
année la plupart s'adapte rapidement au
cadre mais il faut parfois rappeler les
règles avec autorité conseil discipline
ce matin c'est pour traiter une certaine
forme de choses c'est pas la première
fois qu'il a quelques soucis de
discipline ce garçon
le jeu n'aurait trahi une camarade on
divulguant un secret qu'elle lui avait
confié
pour la direction c'est une faute grave
capacité community mais fait preuve
parfois cette année maturité il faut que
ce soit son problème hein
c'est un jeune homme qui travaille bien
certes il manque de maturité mais quand
même c'est un garçon qui est vraiment
bien à qui on peut parler
pas grand chose à rectifier pour qu'il
soit il soit bien on le fait rentrer
s'il vous plaît
vous pouvez m'expliquer les raisons pour
lesquelles vous êtes allé raconter à
tout le monde ce que vous avez confié
dans le camarade de machin m'a posé des
questions et je voulais savoir des
choses j'ai juste répondu aux questions
vous n'avez pas à raconter à vos
camarades parce que il vous a confié
c'est vous qui a employé
donc quand c'est confidentiel on garde
ça pour soi mademoiselle qui est là pour
le défendre allez dites-moi donc moi
j'ai parlé avec lui et Madame
Mademoiselle elle a insulté aussi il y a
pas que lui d'accord
autre chose
moi je m'entends super bien avec lui
j'ai vu que enfin avec les autres aussi
ils sont tombés avec tout le monde et
c'est vrai que c'est un peu trop vite
votre projet professionnel
dites moi où vous en êtes je fais le CV
et la lettre de motivation
à moitié oui
de motivation c'est une page je fais la
moitié donc vous avez rédigé 5 lignes
quoi alors encore un petit effort pour
le 5 suivantes
aussi vous revenez seul
annoncer une telle nouvelle à un élève
est-ce que ça a pas ça risque pas de le
braquer ça risque pas de le
repositionne pas très vite avec un
adoptant une autre posture etc les deux
trois dernières qu'il lui reste il va
continuer à attendre que ça passe on va
arriver à la fin de son contrat il se
sera rien passé donc là l'objectif en
fait du conseil de discipline c'est de
le faire réagir et qu'il y aille voilà
donc c'est pour ça un moment donné c'est
forcément
le conseil de discipline a aussi un but
pédagogique voilà c'est pas sanctionné
pour sanctionner il faut que la sanction
signifie quelque chose
estimé que la faute était grave je pense
pas que cela vous surprenne et donc
décidé de vous exclure de semaine
murissez un peu quoi c'est vous qui avez
les cartes en main c'est pas nous allez
en avant bonne journée
l'exclusion est immédiate mais hors de
question de rester les bras croisés
pendant deux semaines l'élève devra
terminer sa lettre de motivation et
peaufiner son projet professionnel
[Musique]
c'est sa dernière opportunité avant
l'expulsion définitive
[Musique]
à la sortie du conseil je retrouve le
directeur du Centre
donc c'est un peu l'école de la deuxième
chance on peut dire ça ou c'est une
image
si vous voulez donc il est temps de
faire quelque chose que
vous donne une deuxième chance et que il
faut pas se rater c'est comme ça qu'ils
le comprennent absolument
pour un élève le séjour est totalement
gratuit mais il coûte 30 000 euros à
l'état alors ici on ne retient pas ce
qui manque de motivation
dans ces écoles d'insertion
professionnelle on apprend aussi à être
solidaire cet après-midi la section de
Marina et Erickson va donner un coup de
main au Secours populaire de mes yeux
cette activité les jeunes en raffole ils
se sont tous portés volontaires pour
remettre à neuf cette maison
Ericsson ne quitte plus son téléphone la
directrice d'un supermarché doit
l'appeler un poste de magazine est en
jeu
pour me dire que c'est bon ce sera
il faut croiser les doigts
en attendant
Ericsson et Leslie distribuaient
ça touche beaucoup en fait
[Musique]
aider les exclus ça touche ces jeunes
mais ça les angoisse aussi
c'est tellement dur maintenant que que
on a tous envie de se donner les moyens
de travailler et tout et on a tous peur
au fond même ceux qui ont du travail de
se retrouver à la rue de patron ils sont
ils sont durs quoi ils ne laissent pas
de chance en fait même il demande de
l'expérience et quand on sort de l'école
des fois on n'a pas d'expérience moment
de détente mérité pour les jeunes en
compagnie de Daniel et Chloé les deux
moniteurs
Ericsson lui ne tient plus il décide
d'appeler la directrice du supermarché
malheureusement le job ne sera pas pour
lui
c'est un coup dur pour Ericsson il était
convaincu d'en avoir fini avec l'Épide
d'être sorti d'affaires c'est pas grave
elle m'a pas appelé et je l'ai appelé je
l'ai appelé et elle m'a dit ça
moi ça me laisse un peu je comprends que
ça vous ça vous embête un petit peu là
Monsieur Gomez
j'ai bien vu je comprends que c'est
vachement compliqué là pour vous vous
étiez limite à deux doigts de partir là
on s'est un peu enflammé aussi mais
c'est pas fini on a envoyé beaucoup
beaucoup de lettres de motivation et de
CV monsieur Gomez regardez Intermarché
là quand est-ce qu'il vous ont appelé
aujourd'hui hier et voilà donc vous
voyez ça commence à redescendre petit à
petit
faut pas non faut pas vous démotiver là
je vous ai vu avec la banane pendant 48
heures il faut garder la même motivation
on y retourne c'est pas terminé vous
savez combien de cv lettre de motivation
j'ai envoyé moi pour être pris pour être
embauché finalement à lipides 250
au bout d'un moment voilà moi aussi je
me disais je sers à rien machin truc et
finalement j'ai trouvé l'épi et je
m'éclate maintenant faut tout optimiser
faut voir le positif ça bon dia ok allez
on tourne la page c'est terminé on se
projette on passe sur autre chose on se
retrouve les manches et on y retourne
hein
c'est une sorte d'injustice pour eux
c'est voilà ça leur renvoie je vous dis
à leur passé à leurs échecs c'est un de
plus quoi donc ils ont l'impression que
grâce à l'Épide ils vont réussir et puis
finalement
l'échec existe toujours quoi voilà mais
il existera jusqu'à la fin de la vie et
c'est aussi le but de l'épître de leur
apprendre à rebondir quoi
retour à l'internat les jeunes qui
m'entourent n'ont pas 20 ans et à cet
âge-là on ne pense pas seulement à
trouver du travail
et des filles et des garçons comme ça
toute la journée il y a des amourettes
un peu qui se créent ici
on a beaucoup des histoires d'amour
Lucas voilà c'est lui c'est qui bonjour
monsieur la question était est-ce que
vous avez une petite fiancée ici oui
vous avez rencontré ici donc et c'est
facile d'avoir une histoire d'amour en
Libye
ça parle beaucoup
[Musique]
de savoir les gens
ils sont à l'affût les cadres ils sont
au courant
[Musique]
en plein été sur une plage
avec notre sirène mademoiselle kindins
les internes ont deux heures d'activité
physique par jour
on évite de faire trop de vagues pour
embêter les gens qui viennent qui
viennent nager parmi vous il y en a
certains qui ne sont pas très à l'aise
dans l'eau donc je vous demande pareil
de faire très attention à eux le but
tranquille quoi
l'atelier piscine est sous la
responsabilité de Cédric avant Lépide il
allait sauver des gens aux quatre coins
du monde il faisait des rapatriments
sanitaires
aujourd'hui il aide les jeunes à garder
la tête hors de l'eau
chercher si vous à 10 minutes sous l'eau
je viens
[Musique]
non mais là j'ai peur
Ericsson semble avoir digéré la mauvaise
nouvelle de la journée après tout des
supermarchés il y en a beaucoup d'autres
ça remonte le moral
je voulais faire sur le player
[Musique]
tranquille
il ne savait pas nager
franchement on est pas bien là
franchement les plongeons
de calme
salut Benji ça va
comment ça s'est passé super écoute
j'arrive à la fin de cette immersion
j'ai vécu une expérience vraiment
intéressante et même touchante parce que
tous ces jeunes qu'on a pu côtoyer sont
vraiment vraiment attachant
ici il grandissent ils nous l'ont tous
dit et c'est vraiment poignant même de
voir à quel point ils font des efforts
pour pour réussir à s'en sortir et il
faut juste maintenant espérer que le
marché du travail fasse enfin une place
à ces jeunes qui ont besoin d'un peu
plus de temps que les autres bah écoute
bonne immersion à toi parce que je crois
que c'est ton tour
promis je prendrai des nouvelles allez
je t'embrasse salut
allez s'il vous plaît messieurs dames
mon immersion s'achève comme elle a
commencé devant le drapeau le vendredi
le directeur récompense publiquement les
élèves qui se sont distingués pour ces
jeunes qui n'ont souvent connu que
l'échec ce rituel est très important il
n'y a pas de petit progrès tout avancé
est applaudit
le code
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais également dire un petit mot
sur la section de Monsieur Rodriguez qui
a participé à une distribution de
denrées alimentaires
Muji et Monsieur Nefta
[Applaudissements]
c'est une démarche tout à fait louable
et donc je vous en félicite
de ce centre avec une formation ou un
emploi ici on appelle ça une sortie
positive moi j'y verrai plutôt un pied
de nez au fait Alice ambiant preuve que
quand la République donne une deuxième
chance à des jeunes déterminés tout
n'est pas perdu
[Musique]